Snoop Dogg is giving up Mary Jane
perhaps the most famous puffer of jazz
cabbage in all the land is giving up the
devil's lettuce in an Instagram post Mr
dog wrote after much consider risle and
conversation is no he didn't say that he
said after much consideration and
conversation with my family I've decided
to give up smoke by which he of course
means the Haitian oregano and Snoop
concluded please respect my privacy at
this time many fans of the felonius
rapper are rushing to all sorts of
conclusions as to why he might give up
the sin spinach after all these years
and to them I say hold up hey for all
those fellas who be thinking he's soft
Snoop don't play I'm confident that he
is going to rock it till the wheels fall
off I say hold up hold up hey for all
those fellas who be acting too bold take
a seat
I hope you're ready for the next
episode I'm Michael nolles this is the
Michael Nolls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show for those
just listening I want to make it
perfectly clear
I am implying that Snoop is going to
switch to smoking Mayflower cigars that
is I don't I know if you saw if you're
watching it you saw me point at the buck
I want I don't want anyone to miss my
implication here also speaking of Pop
Culture Joe Rogan and The Rock are
trashing Joe Biden we'll get to that in
just a moment first though speaking of
people who are obviously under the
influence of mind altering drugs the
libs have gone from trashing America
to endorsing some of America's enemies
to undercutting America's position in
the world to
now
outright endorsing Osama Bin Laden the
latest Tik Tok
Trend this gal she goes me when I got
news in 2011 that we got him yes yeah
great 2023 reading osama's letter to
America knowing he was right he was
right actually before you even read the
letter I did want to men
in reading the letter I could only think
of this tweet that I saw the other day
under settler colonialism any kind of
resistance is branded as terrorist
because the only acceptable violence is
Violence by the occupier so please keep
that in mind when reading the letter um
we really need to stop paying taxes
because they ain't doing nothing but
messing up everybody else and and
America is the bully it is sad because
they have brainwashed us letter to
America in my opinion take or leave it
when in reality we're the worst country
in the planet it is just insane because
this letter is so well written and so
reasonably structured um in an argument
like you got to present your findings
you got to you know you got to State
your cause all that like everything he
said was valid
H if you haven't read it Osama Bin Laden
wrote this letter to America after the
911 attacks and I guess Zoomers are just
discovering that I remember reading the
letter many many years ago but the
Zoomers have just discovered it but they
seem to be selectively reading the
letter I'm I'm very excited for the the
libs who are promoting the letter to
America by Osama Bin Laden I can't wait
for these Libs all of whom voted for
Hillary in 2016 to get to the part of
the letter where Osama justifies the
9/11 attacks in part on America's
failure to punish Bill Clinton for the
Monica Lewinsky Affair I can't wait for
them to read the part of the letter the
many parts of the letter that
contradict all of their behavior I'll
just give you a little snippet the
letter the letter is not too long but
I'll just give you a little snippet here
Osama Bin Laden in the letter to America
writes why are we fighting and opposing
you what are we calling you to and what
do we want from you because you attacked
us and continue to attack us you
attacked us in Palestine Palestine which
has sunk under military occupation for
more than 80 years the British handed
over Palestine with your help and
support to the Jews who have occupied it
for more than 50 years okay that's the
part that the libs like because the libs
are anti-colonialism
anti-imperialism anti- settler
anti-white people anti-british
anti-American and anti-jew okay they
like that part keep reading
though the people of Palestine are pure
Arabs and original semites it is the
Muslims who are the inheritors of Moses
Moes peace be upon him and the
inheritors of the real Torah that has
not been changed Muslims believe in all
of the prophets including Abraham Moses
Jesus and Muhammad okay do they believe
that part do they believe there's
obviously been a dispute for a long time
between the Muslims who believe that
they are the descendants of Abraham
through Ishmael and the Jews who are the
descendants of Abraham through Isaac and
uh you know in in the Book of Genesis
it's pretty clear that those two lines
are not going to get along very well
then you add the Christians into the mix
the Christians who view the church as
the Fulfillment of the Old Testament and
the Fulfillment of the old Covenant and
who view our Lord Jesus Christ as the
new Adam and who view the churches the
new Israel and things start to get
really really complicated here do the
libs really they believe in all of that
maybe they do maybe they do they say
yeah the the Arabs they're the real
semites and the Jews they're not okay
well what about this one you attack in
Somalia you supported the Russian
atrocities against us in Chia the Indian
oppression against us in Kashmir and the
Jewish aggression against us in Lebanon
yeah yeah that's right go go get them
Osama say the libs that's right those
Americans they keep they keep uh
interfering in places all over the world
okay then then though you get a turn
this is why the American people cannot
be innocent of all the crimes committed
by the Americans and Jews against us
what are we calling you to what do we
want from you the first thing is that we
are calling you to Islam so all these
livs here you know many of whom are
Reddit tier atheists I suspect do they
agree with that part of the Osama letter
that they all need to convert to Islam
that Islam is the true religion and they
all need to convert By The Sword is that
something tells me that the tick tock
libs are not quite on board with that
one how about this one we call you to be
a people of manners principles honor and
Purity to reject the immoral acts of
fornication homosexuality intoxicant
gambling
and trading with
interest they agree do they agree with
that
one do they did they put the bong down
long enough to to agree with Osama that
any use or production or trading in any
kind of intoxicating substances
whatsoever is extremely Haram and needs
to be stopped what about homosexuality
and fornication for that matter are they
going to be cheering on that part of the
Osama Bin Laden letter at their next
Pride Parade is there there's going to
be a section of the of drag queen Story
Hour where they read Osama Bin Laden's
letter about how terrible fornication
and homosexuality are the libs embracing
that part they say it's saddening that
you to tell you that you are the worst
civilization witnessed by the history of
mankind certainly the libs agree with
that you are a nation who rather than
ruling by the Sharia of Allah in its
Constitution and laws chose to invent
your own laws as your will and desire uh
I guess I guess that's true but the the
libs like that that's exactly how the
libs view the law the libs view the law
not as something that comes from an
eternal moral order or an ordinance of
God but rather as something that we just
invent man you know it's just whatever
the people want that's what we get you
know man so uh they probably don't agree
with that part uh then he goes after the
drugs again and then and then my
favorite part of the letter who can
forget your President Clinton's immoral
acts committed in the official Oval
Office after that you did not even bring
him to account other than that he made a
mistake at after which everything passed
with no punishment is there a worse kind
of event for which your name will go
down in history and remembered be
remembered by Nations I love that all
these Lives who if they were alive
during the Clinton era excused him
defended him said that's his private
life he every man has the right to
privacy when he's boinking an intern in
the Oval Office ABS how dare you suggest
otherwise that's why we support Osama
Bin Laden now it seems a little
confusing not to put too fine a point on
it you don't actually have to hand it to
Osama Bin Laden you never you never have
to hand it to him he doesn't have to
have a point it's
okay the libs though are attracted to
the letter by Bin Laden in part because
they hate America and he hates America
so the enemy of my enemy is my friend
but but also in part I think for the
same reason that young men living in
Great
Britain 10 years ago young men who maybe
were immigrants or the children of
immigrants but who grew up in perfectly
bgea British middle class lives decided
to give it all up and join Isis forget
about the Immigrant people even the
white guys there were white people who
would go join Isis why it seems insane
why would you leave Britain or France or
America even to go fight for some
Islamic militant group
because you read that letter by the the
by Osama Bin Laden or any of the radical
Muslims and you see that these people
believe in something they believe in
something Beyond mere physical comfort
and and that is
attractive but unfortunately those guys
never ask the next question well what is
it that they believe in yes there's
something beyond the material world but
what is it that they believe in is what
they believe in true or is what they
believe in false is what they believe in
good or is what they believe in Wicked
and furthermore what should we believe
in are we all just going to become
Muslims because Osama Bin Laden told us
to I don't think so maybe I don't know
it's more compelling than just sit
around on your iPhone and believe in
nothing I guess but the reason the
reason that the libs in the year of Our
Lord 2023 can post a Tik Tok Trend like
this and be be swayed by the the ravings
of a Muslim terrorist from 20 years ago
is because we don't know what we believe
anymore we had a religion too we had a
civilization too we had beliefs beyond
the physical Comforts of this world too
and we have consistently given them up
for intoxicating drugs for weird sex
stuff
for derelict Behavior even among
our most prominent politicians that yeah
we did give all that up and that now we
have a crisis of faith and a crisis of
identity and as the cliche goes if you
don't stand for something you will fall
for anything we got to talk about these
things when you want to talk you got to
check out P talk right now go to Pur
talk.com if you're looking for a killer
Black Friday deal
I've got one for you a free Moto
g5g phone from Pure Talk no gimmicks no
trade in necessary just sign up for p
talks unlimited talk unlimited text and
15 kig data you can get all this for
just 35 bucks you will get the Moto g5g
phone for free phones these days cost so
much money well you get it for free the
new Moto g5g boasts a two-day battery
life that's outrageous an exceptional
quad pixel camera and a whole lot more
this is a great deal but you will need
to move fast because the phones will be
sold out by the end of the month so if
your current phone is on the way out
upgrade for free with P talk P talk
gives you America's most Dependable 5G
Network at half the price make the
switch today go to Pur talk.com
nscw to get this exclusive offer and
select the plan that is right for your
family that is Pur talk.com nscw to
claim your free Moto g5g phone with a
qualifying plan that is p
talk.com canw Pure Talk simply smarter
Wireless speaking of political
activism the governor of California
governor Patrick baitman doing business
as Gavin Nome has a new booster maybe a
new endorser and that person would
be President Joe Biden I want to talk
about Governor Nome want to thank him
he's been one hell of a governor
man matter of fact he could be anything
you want he could have the job I'm
looking
for whoa hold on everybody knows that
Gavin Newsome is running for president
he hasn't declared but he is effectively
running for president he's traveling the
country he's talking to the press and
saying you know if only I were president
ha I'm just kidding I'm just being
sarcastic but you know if only I could
be president there'd be a lot of things
I would do and so what's going on here
is is Biden teasing
him is Biden warning him is he saying
hey pal I know what you're up to wait
your turn
or is he suggesting that he would hand
over the Reigns to Gavin
Newsome it could be any of those options
but it it certainly could be the latter
Joe Biden is very old I don't think he
wants to willingly give up power the
man's wanted to be president since he
was in the womb I don't think he just
wants to give it up willy-nilly and go
down as a one-term president but he's
super old and he is not up to the job
and this is what's crucial he hates his
vice president he hates her she her
presidential
campaign was was oriented toward calling
him a racist remember that was kamala's
big moment during the 2020 debates was
saying Joe Biden is a racist and he put
black men in prison and he opposed
busing and didn't want me a little girl
kamla Harris to get a good education
that was it that was her that was her
Chief pitch at the debates he doesn't
like her he only picked her because he
boxed himself into a corner and said I
have to pick a black woman to be my VP
and the options before him of prominent
black women who could have been chosen
for that job were Susan Rice Susan Rice
who was the fall man for Obama in
Benghazi that wasn't going to work Karen
bass who's an actual communist and not a
very impressive woman and kamla Harris
who's also not that impressive but was
relatively moderate and could have
plausibly gone along with the Biden
line but he doesn't like her who's he
gonna pick he's gonna pick Pete Budaj
Pete Budaj is not going to happen guys I
know that there were some over
credentialed upper middle class Suburban
white liberals who were on the Pete
train but Pete ain't going anywhere okay
to quote Donald Trump Alfred Newman is
never going to be president of the
United States it's not going to happen
especially after Pete Budaj screwed up
the easiest job in the US government
Transportation secretary you should not
know the name of the transportation
secretary and yet that guy managed to
screw it up with many Transportation
crises under his Reign which he wasn't
even for because he was on maternity
leave somehow so it's not going to be
him it could be Nome Newsome is a very
impressive political figure and Joe
Biden's numbers are in the absolute
doldrums so there is a possibility that
if if he is not going to win if if his
party is going to turn against him if he
gently anoints his successor that might
look better for his legacy than if he
gets tossed out by his own party but his
party doesn't like him you know Joe
Rogan was just talking to the Rock and
Joe Rogan is an independent voter he was
a Bernie bro then he signal that he kind
of liked Trump he never really liked
Biden probably to establishment for Joe
he's talking to The Rock The Rock for
many years has been rumored to be a
republican but he's endorsed plenty of
lib stuff I think he endorsed Biden in
2020 these these guys are probably
pretty decent reflections of the
American populace at large here here's
their conversation about the sitting
president of the United States when I
was a
kid you could have a republican friend
like it it was no big deal yes it's no
big deal like oh Bobby likes George Bush
who cares who gives a you know you were
a supporter of Bill Clinton he lik
George Bush nobody cared nobody like you
you know it wasn't like you're a Nazi
like I'm a what I mean I'm a Nazi I just
want lower
taxes what the are you talking about how
did I become a Nazi dude it's it's the
craziest thing I have friends who
support Trump I have friends who support
Biden I have friends do you really have
friends who support Biden come on well
no no no no no here here's what I do I
have I have friends thank you that's a
good check cuz that's important this is
important context they support the
Democratic party I have friends who are
loyal to the party
yes no
devastating and really great catch by
Joe because the rock is trying to do
this thing that entertainers have done
since Michael Jordan and long before
that long before Michael Jordan he made
it Famous by saying well Republicans buy
sneakers too but it's the notion that I
don't want to alienate either side of
the political aisle so I'm yeah I've got
friends who who support Trump I have
friends who support Biden and Joe just
leans in he goes BS no you don't nobody
supports Biden I know for a fact you
don't have a single friend who supports
Biden right and The Rock looks at him he
knows he's caught and he goes yeah okay
you're right yeah but I have Democrat
friends but even the Democrats hate Joe
Biden and they don't hate him with
passion I guess that's that's even more
of an indictment of Biden nobody
passionately hates Joe Biden he's
just so so
unimpressive he's just the guy who was
there I mean in part that's why he got
elected yeah that's the ticket that's
how he wound up president
is because he was just totally
acceptable and not exceptional or
impressive in any way he had been around
Washington DC since
1752 and he had never rocked the boat
too much he doesn't really believe
anything he'll just go wherever he feels
the wind of his party is blowing e even
his corruption is not that impressive
Clinton corruption is really impressive
the clintons formed this Foundation they
went all over the world they collected a
ton of money they shook down for foreign
governments totally in public view Bill
Clinton's flying around at Jeffrey
Epstein's private airplane he's
flaunting it they're flaunting their
corruption it was so outrageous and in
your- face Joe Biden he's sending his
son around his drug addled son to go
shake down some oligarchs in Ukraine or
in China or it's kind of behind the
scenes and it's just even that even the
corruption is just so
mediocre nobody supports him so what's
what's that going to mean it's going to
mean that if the election is fair and if
the Republicans can fix the way that the
Dems rigged the voting in 2020 then a
republican has a pretty good chance of
winning and who is that Republican going
to be almost certainly it's going to be
Trump but on the undercard right now
among the people who are running for
that number two spot if something
happens to Trump if they finally take
him out of the race then that that
person's going to be ready in the Wings
To Go most people thought it was going
to be DeSantis but the person making the
biggest moves right now would appear to
be
Nikki Haley we'll get to that in one
second first though you want to look
good you got to look good in politics
you got to look good in your life you
know come on if look good feel good
means you got to check out jell right
now go to genucell.com if you can
believe it Thanksgiving is next week
just in time for the holidays genus cell
is offering their best sale of the year
right now you can get 70 70% off genus
cell's most popular package which now
includes genus cell 3 their newest under
ey treatment genus cell 3 will have you
looking 10 50 even 20 years younger it
uses advanced technology to deliver
complex vitamins and minerals directly
to your face for instant hydration say
goodbye to Fine Lines crows feet under
eye bags and dark spots genus cell will
have you looking and feeling your
absolute best guaranteed or your money
back no questions asked our talent
manager Tessa loves using the genucel
under eye cream a lot of people at this
office love genucel but I can't tell you
how good they all look because HR will
yell at me if I do that but genell this
is the real deal man the genus cell
products are all made with the absolute
highest quality ingredients and right
now you can get an incredible 70 70% off
at Jus cell.com I asked how can you
afford to to Discount this
70% is it just a big markup and I was
talking this to the founder of the
company and he said no no we're going to
lose money when we do that but we are so
confident that you're going to love the
products that you're going to keep
getting the products for years and years
into the future get results in 12 hours
or less the immediate effects are
included for free Jus cell.com 70% off
plus free priority shipping jus.com
my favorite comment yesterday's from
David Aloha 5084 who says if an American
statesman visited China do you think
they would hang red white and blue
banners to make him feel more at home uh
they would if America were China's
biggest creditor they probably would
that's that's an underd discussed aspect
of the story of San Francisco being
painted red for xiin ping
everyone they clean up the city for
years we're told we can't clean up San
Francisco we need to let the homeless
drug addled criminals run rough shot
over all innocent people and have filth
throughout the streets and then they
find out that the Communist dictator of
China is Coming to Town wh overnight
boom here we go everything's clean then
they've got red flags hanging from the
buildings yeah well in part that's
because the Liberals like Chinese
Communists more than they like us but
two China's our creditor man they own a
ton of our debt we need them to keep
lending US money or we won't be able to
sustain our bloated and decadent Empire
so yeah if the roles were reversed they
probably would hang a little red white
and blue in the streets that's that's
how Empires
work back to the presidential race Nikki
Haley surging and she is going after one
man in particular and that would be Mr V
ramaswami what happens he comes out of
the gate he
hits the female chair of the party he
hits the female anchor on the platform
and then he hits me and I'm not saying
anything I ain't saying I'm just saying
but he might have a girl problem I'm
just saying he might have a girl problem
so Nikki and V obviously do not like
each other very much V in the last
debate called Nikki Haley Dick Cheney
and 3-in
heels at one point point he he went
after Nikki's uh association with the
defense industry and then the part that
really got under her skin he after she
had attacked him for being on Tik Tok or
her campaign had attacked him or
something like that he went after her
and said well your daughter was on Tik
Tok at which point she said you are scum
on the debate stage and now she's saying
you know he's got a problem with women
basically so a lot of conservatives are
going to recoil against this and say oh
Nikki that's a liberal tactic you're
playing the woman card this is some
feminist stuff you'd see out of the
Democratic Party come on give me a break
but my answer to that is I don't know
why shouldn't she play it why not it's
politics this is a dirty business this
is a dirty nasty business they're all
going to rip each other apart and so if
that's if that is a card that Nikki has
got up her sleeve that she thinks is
going to work I don't know it's a it's a
tactic I don't know it's not a tactic
that I would use in part because I'm a
man but you know she's a a woman and can
play that card okay fine if I were
advising her campaign I would have
cautioned against that a little bit as I
would say well Republicans don't like
identity politics they don't like the
feminist stuff maybe it's I just don't
think it's going to be effective but it
would appear that I would have been
wrong in that advice because Nikki's
campaign is doing great it's not doing
great great in that Donald Trump is
still 50 points above everybody just
about but it's doing great relative to
the rest of the undercard Nikki is
surging and according to a new Emerson
poll Nikki is now in second place in New
Hampshire Ronda santis is down to fourth
place in New
Hampshire now the real headline of the
poll is Donald Trump has 49% in New
Hampshire so statistically half of New
Hampshire voters in a field that's still
what six
people I guess Tim Scott's dropped out
so now it's five people Trump still has
50% of the V it's not even close but
Nikki is now in second place she's got
18 points and she's ahead of everyone
else including Ryan the santis so the
field is winnowing and I always feared
this would happen for
disantis who I really like Who I Really
support who I think is a really good
politician but as I've said before I
won't be labor the point he was kind of
a man without a home because the thing
that made him so great is the pitch that
he was Trump two .0 bigger better faster
stronger more disciplined more this more
that uh but his role in the race was to
be the anti-trump
candidate which the campaign seemed to
believe meant he he would have the best
of both worlds he could pull from the
Trump supporters and he could pull from
the political establishment but in
reality he he seems to have alienated
both camps because the real Trump
supporters support Trump they got the OG
in the race they're not going to support
the new guy and the establishment
doesn't like what Ronda Sanz has
actually accomplished in Florida which
is being much more conservative kicking
the woke stuff out of the classroom
going after Disney wielding the power of
the State against corporations sending
migrants sending the illegal aliens up
to Martha's Vineyard that's stuff that I
love I coming from the conservative wing
of the party but it's not going to win
you any support among the never trumpers
or the establishment so then you're a
man without a home and someone like
Nikki Haley who has styled herself for
her whole career as a much more moderate
Centrist kind of Republican she might be
able to take that
support it's it's that old adage if you
stand in the middle of the road you
might get hit by a truck there's at
least Clarity I don't think that's going
to work for Nikki Haley in the end I
still think Trump is going to keep his
50% and walk away with the nomination
barring some unforeseen catastrophe but
it could give her a better shot at
second place now on the Democrat side
there's another man running for
president potentially that would be West
Virginia senator Joe Mansion Are you
seriously contemplating a run for the
white house I'm going to do everything
in my power to make sure and mobilize
that moderate sensible Common Sense
middle that could be a center left
center right so it could be a person who
is involved in the grand old party
forever but they basically said well you
know my Democrat friends over here the
old Blue Dog Democrats The Middle's gone
there's not many of us centrists left
and if I can reinvigorate that and I
said I will do everything that I
possibly can I'm totally absolutely
scared to death that Donald Trump would
become president again I think we will
lose democracy as we need know it I do
just want to stick with what your
thinking is right now just to clarify
just to put a fine point I know you
haven't made any decisions but are you
considering running for president I will
do anything I can to help my country is
that a yes and you're saying does that
mean you would consider it absolutely
every American should consider if
they're in a position to help save the
country I think we're on the wrong
course so I will do everything
possible he wants to run he obviously
wants to run
and he's he apparently explored No
Labels run as an independent candidate
now he could he could run as a Democrat
to me the key here the key figure in his
thinking is
not Joe Biden to me the key figure in
his thinking is RFK Jr he RFK Jr is
styling himself as a 1960s Democrat I'm
a Kennedy Democrat you know I look my
name is Kennedy I'm a Kennedy Democrat
and I'm a little more moderate and a
little more Centrist and that's why you
should vote for me and Joe mansion's
looking at that and saying hey Bobby
Kennedy you're not a Centrist what are
you talking about you're an extreme
liberal on most issues other than the
covid vaccines which is why you have
some conservative support but but a lot
especially in the environment for
goodness sakes you're an extreme liberal
and you you've convinced people you're a
moderate and you're walking away with
one fif of the Democrat vote right now
whoa and there was a poll that came out
last week in a three-way race you put a
real Dent you you're a real player in
this race whoa well if you're the fake
moderate what about me I'm an actual
moderate I'm Joe Mansion I'm the
Centrist guy Everyone likes me in the
Senate I'm I'm a I'm like a big cool
football quarterback you know I'm the
guy in high school that everybody likes
even the Democrats and the Republicans I
I pal around with everybody maybe I
should run that's what we're seeing here
now before we get to the mailbag my
favorite time of the week I do want to
get to someone who will not be running
for re-election that is George
Santos George Santos is not running you
know he's the guy who he got caught with
all these lies and deceptions and frauds
and he's a really colorful character out
of New York I have defended George
Santos from
resigning uh for for a long time more
than most other Republicans probably and
the reason for that is that Santo I'm
not denying that Santos has done all
sorts of terrible things or that he's a
disreputable figure I'm I like that D
Santos is in the Congress because so
many of the other Democrats who pretend
to be respectable have done the same
things oh what happened George Santos
lied about his ethnic background gee you
know okay talk to me more about that
Elizabeth Warren OH George Santos had
some corrupt Financial dealings oh tell
me more about that Joe Biden what I
liked about Santos in the Congress is
that he just exposes the iniquity and
the hypocrisy of the libs which I think
is terrific but I'm not calling on him
to resign but he says he's not going to
run for re-election because of this
ethics probe I do want to point out
while I get get a kick out of Santos
because he is a meme and because he he
shows the Democrats for what they
are fraud is really bad the stuff he's
accused of and it seems like there's
good evidence of is is not only that he
defrauded people but that he defrauded
his benefactors and that he appears to
have a consistent track record of doing
this for his whole life and that is
really bad fraud treachery defrauding
your benefactors in particular is in the
Divine Comedy the very lowest of all
sins that puts you in the very pit of
Hell being nashed in the mouth of Satan
because it is a sin against love and
against voluntary love and it's just so
profoundly evil and so I don't want to
gloss over that he's funny he's a meme I
get a kick out of it I'm not going to
call on him to resign but I'm not upset
that he's not running for reelection you
know it's it's all fun in games until
you're being nashed in one of the mouths
of Satan in the lake coitis
the cittis river in the very pit of Hell
then it then it's a little bit less
funny Black Friday is coming and the
daily wire has the best deals around
starting Monday get 50% 50% off a daily
wire plusus membership and all kinds of
amazing deals on Jeremy's razor products
and tons of merch from our dailywire
shop there is something for everyone go
to dailywire.com blackf Friday and get
the full guide to all of our Black
Friday deals do not forget to tune in
all next week find out more remember
these deals start on Monday run through
Cyber Monday but we will sell out fast
do not wait get the guide and start
checking off your holiday shopping list
one more time dailywire.com blackf
Friday for the best deals of the Year
all right it's time for the mailbag this
mailbag is sponsored by P talk go to Pur
talk.com canw today to claim your free
Moto G 5G phone with a qualifying plan
take it away hello Mr nlls it is daily
wire's favorite bass player coming at
you with another question
congratulations on the cigars by the way
as an avid cigar afficionado myself and
you being the inspiration for me
starting a cigar club in The Unofficial
dailywire Discord I wanted to wonder
would you ever consider going on a cigar
tour to have cigars with the fellow
de I can happily say that I've had a
cigar with Mr Davies uh in this Discord
I know you would probably get swarmed
fans if you were to partake in such a
thing but would you ever consider
bringing your cigars to a local cigar
shop in States across the country and
sell tickets for people to sit down and
have a cigar with you or would that be
too risky anyway I'll let you know what
I think of the Mayflower once I receive
it thank you you know I think that's a
great idea I I think that's a really
great idea and I'd love to do it I am a
fixture at at cigar lounges is all
around the country truly when I go to a
new city anywhere in the country really
anywhere in the world certainly in the
country though the first thing I look up
where's the nearest cigar bar because
usually I'm traveling to go give a
speech or do some political event and or
even if I'm traveling Just For Pleasure
with my family once the kids go to sleep
I'm probably going to go want to go have
a cigar and so it's the first thing I
look up so I've I've been to not saying
I've been to every Cigar Lounge in the
country but I've been to a
disproportionate number of them
throughout these beautiful United States
and my only hold up on doing a Lounge
event a formal one
is you know it's a it's a pleasure
activity for me so I don't know if I
love the idea of formalizing it in a you
know you get tickets and there seats and
it's a lounge it's a much more relaxed
kind of culture than that uh and two the
beauty of a cigar lounge and
conversations in cigars is that they're
intimate you know it's just a small
number of people so you know you do do
the big event where you got 600 people
in an auditorium or something and but
then afterward you go out with six
people and have a cigar you know that's
kind of more the the vibe that I'd be
looking for so I like the we got to do
something with the cigars I totally
agree we got to do some kind of event
but I got to work at exactly what that
is next question hi Michael I've
recently started looking into
Catholicism and I have a question for
you so I grew up as an Evangelical and
the biggest reservation I've had with
Catholicism was that pretty consistently
growing up I noticed that my Catholic
peers seemed to know the rituals know
the surface level stuff but beyond that
there were some pretty major gaps in
their biblical knowledge and only
recently have I started to question this
and even consider Catholicism because I
feel like listening to you and Matt talk
that seemed to contradict that idea that
I had so I've attended two masses one
was a Latin Mass but I noticed both
times the homy it did seem service level
both I don't know if this is a
coincidence but both times the priest
talked about love and he said nice
things about it he didn't say untrue
things but I didn't learn anything
neither of them referenced scripture in
their sermon and to me this seemed to
affirm my previous reservation that
Catholic churches don't teach the word
when I compare it to my Baptist Church
where our pastors will spend months
going through one book in the Bible
we're going through 2 Chronicles right
now and I feel like I'm learning a lot
that I don't think I would be able to
with my own study um so I'd love your
thoughts on this thanks Michael great
question uh it it varies greatly among
Catholic parishes I I've been very lucky
in that uh my Parish the homes are ex
extremely intellectual and rigorous and
all those things and that's been true of
parishes I've gone to in Los Angeles and
New York and but I've I've also been to
the ones where the homy seems to have
nothing to do with scripture and seems
to be a little breezier uh all of that
is kind of beside the point though
because what you're coming up against is
a
fundamental distinction in what the mass
is versus a lot of other kind of um
religious
Services the Holy Mass is not a
classroom it is not a lecture hall it is
not primarily about teaching you some
aspect of scripture the Holy Mass is a
sacrifice there are other places to go
learn things and listen to lectures and
read your Bible and there Bible studies
for goodness sakes the most popular
podcast in the country at least for a
long period of time was Bible in a year
with father Mike Schmitz which is a a
Catholic Bible study 365 days through
the Bible and then one of the other most
popular podcasts was uh the catechism in
a year with also with father Mike schm
very popular podcaster so you can go
there there are wonderful lectures to go
to there are wonderful groups outside of
mass but mass is not just about teaching
or even primarily about teaching it's
about the Holy sacrifice it's about
worship and and those are different
things and they both have their place
but that's the mass is the highest form
of prayer and so one way to think about
it I think it was Scott Han actually the
Theologian who was on the show yesterday
I think I got this point from him that
you might think about it as the
distinction between the temple and the
synagogue
the temple is for sacrifice the
synagogue is largely directed toward
teaching and exegesis and but those are
those are distinct functions and so
there's a little uh Comfort there
there's a lot of comfort there too
because it means that if you go to a
mass and the homy is really brilliant
and profound and deep and aidite well
great all the better I love that but
that's not what you're going there for
you're going there for the the holy
sacrifice of the Mask in in the blessing
Sacrament in the Holy Eucharist okay
next question hi Michael Arun here I
watched with great interest and
enjoyment your reaction video to that
PhD lady uh with the Apparently with the
low IQ um one reason I found it
interesting is because we on the right
regularly and rightly mock people who
wave around their phds and then espouse
leftist talking points and usually these
people have phds in ridiculous and
intellectually vacuous top ICS like
gender studies or cultural anthropology
you know I I don't even know what that
one is but but this lady had a PhD in a
real subject I think it was cancer
biology and as someone who likewise has
an actual PhD in my case particle asop
physics I know that this woman wasn't
just sitting in classrooms being
indoctrinated she was probably working
in a lab or sitting behind a screen and
doing statistical analysis so she seems
like she would be a fairly intelligent
person person and yet you know she uh
she she didn't do so well on the test of
that intelligence and that leads me to
wonder what do we mean when we talk
about intelligence what does it mean to
say that someone is a smart person uh
and I'm not talking about wisdom here
I'm just talking about you know what we
think of as intelligence uh could you
provide a functional definition that we
could use when we are talking about
whether someone is smart or uh or stupid
thank you as always for your wisdom and
of course for your intelligence well
thank you very much Aron excellent
question as always to the first part of
your
question I just don't know how she ended
up in that program I don't know how she
graduated from that
program I agree with you that if if you
have a PhD in cancer biology or particle
astrophysics you are much more likely to
be certainly particle as astrophysics
you're much more likely to be
intelligent than someone who has a PHD
and some some fake nonsense critical
studies Department uh but even in the
harder sciences and the more serious
academic
disciplines the universities have over
the last many decades lowered standards
because they insist on uh social
engineering and filling the ranks with
certain politically correct groups and
so I I just don't know how rigorous her
education was I don't remember exactly
which schools she went to I don't
remember how much active recruit recting
of whatever politically correct grieved
groups you can check the boxes for uh
took place at that school I don't know
how much of her work in Publications is
actually her own work and how much of it
is she just put her name as a co-author
on some paper so there there is a lot of
wiggle room in there for someone to get
that kind of a credential without really
having the the intellectual fortitude to
to do it herself uh but as for a working
definition of intelligence it would seem
to me that the intellect is the the
highest uh faculty of the
soul and uh that It ultimately comes
down to Discerning truth from falsehood
so you are keenly drawing a distinction
between intelligence and wisdom I'm not
sure that they're quite so easily
separated you know given the distinction
that you're making then one would have
to say that intelligence is just you
know the the U sheer ability to focus
and process information over time right
they it's just a like like some engines
run a little faster than other engines
is I given the distinction you're making
but I'm not sure it totally works like
that which is why I don't deny the the
reality of natural advantages things
like IQ but I I also don't put too much
stock in them because it just seems to
me that uh people who are are who have a
a raw intelligence that's very very high
but who are trained in habits of the
intellect and and habits more broadly of
of the the will that are uh not
conducive to Discerning truth and beauty
and goodness those people are going to
wind up seeming really stupid later down
the road and even people who don't have
quite as uh robust a natural
intelligence people who are are well
formed and trained in wisdom are just
going to come off as much much smarter I
mean frankly you see this in a lot of
the I travel to a lot of universities
the universities that supposedly have
the absolute highest tippity top
standards when it comes to sat act
standardized testing a lot of those kids
come off as pretty dumb because they
don't know anything I mean they're
they're they're the things they know
they don't know very well and many of
the things they know just aren't true at
all and then they they show great
ignorance in basic aspects of of
knowledge that they should have had a
decade prior whereas you go to schools
that don't require such high SATs but
they're a little more properly uh
ordered and those kids know their
Aristotle much better than I do you know
so uh I'm I I guess I just am skeptical
that you can actually separate those two
things in a very
mechanistic industrial computerized way
you know it tends to be that our
theories of the Mind are uh reflect the
dominant Technologies of our era you see
this with uh Freud in the steam engine
you see this today with the computer we
talk about processing information I just
did it myself we talk about downloading
information or uploading our
Consciousness or whatever and I I just
don't know that you can really separate
those okay we've got more to get more
mailbag and fake headline Friday the
rest of the show continues now you do
not want to miss it become a member and
use code NES KW at check out for 2
months free on all annual
[Music]
plans